well I mean the first thing to say is
that acid today there are no leave
campaigns who voted to leave the
campaign's become people who were - to
be continued let's listen to the Prime
Minister good morning everyone
the country has just taken part in a
giant Democratic exercise perhaps the
biggest in our history over 33 million
people from England Scotland Wales
Northern Ireland and Gibraltar have all
had their say we should be proud of the
fact that in these islands we trust the
people with these big decisions we not
only have a parliamentary democracy but
on questions about the arrangements for
how we're governed there are times when
it is right to ask the people themselves
and that is what we have done the
British people have voted to leave the
European Union and their will must be
respected I want to thank everyone who
took part in the campaign on my side of
the argument including all those who put
put aside party differences to speak in
what they believed was the national
interest and let me congratulate all
those who took part in the leave
campaign for the spirited and passionate
case that they made the will of the
British people is an instruction that
must be delivered it was not a decision
that was taken lightly not least because
so many things were said by so many
different organizations about the
significance of this decision so there
can be no doubt about the result across
the world people have been watching the
choice that Britain has made I would
reassure those markets and investors
that Britain's economy is fundamentally
strong and I would also reassure Brits
living in European countries and
European citizens living here that there
will be no immediate changes in your
circumstances there will be no initial
change in the way our people can travel
in the way our Goods can move or the way
our services can be sold we must now
prepare for a negotiation with the
European Union
this will need to involve the full
engagement of the Scottish Welsh and
Northern Ireland governments to ensure
that the interests of all parts of our
United Kingdom are protected and
advanced but above all this will require
strong determined and committed
leadership I'm very proud and very
honored to have been prime minister of
this country for six years I believe
we've made great steps with more people
in work than ever before in our history
with reforms to welfare and education
increasing people's life chances
building a bigger and stronger society
keeping our promises to the poorest
people in the world and enabling those
who love each other to get married
whatever their sexuality but above all
restoring Britain's economic strength
and I'm grateful to everyone who's
helped to make that happen I've also
always believed that we have to confront
big decisions not dark them that is why
we delivered the first coalition
government in 70 years to bring our
economy back from the brink it's why we
delivered a fair legal and decisive
referendum in Scotland and it's why I
made the pledge to renegotiate Britain's
position in the European Union and to
hold a referendum on our membership and
have carried those things out I fought
this campaign in the only way I know how
which is to say directly and
passionately what I think and feel head
heart and soul I held nothing back
I was absolutely clear about my belief
that Britain is stronger safer and
better off inside the European Union and
I made clear the referendum was about
this and this alone not the future of
any single politician including myself
but the British people have made a very
clear decision to take a different path
and as such I think the country requires
fresh leadership to take it in this
direction
I will do everything I can as prime
minister to steady the ship over the
coming weeks and months but I do not
think it would be right for me to try to
be the captain that steers our country
to its next destination this is not a
decision I've taken lightly but I do
believe it's in the national interest to
have a period of stability and then the
new leadership required there is no need
for a precise timetable today but in my
view we should aim to have a new prime
minister in place by the start of the
Conservative Party conference in October
delivering stability will be important
and I will continue in post as Prime
Minister
with my cabinet for the next three
months the cabinet will meet on Monday
the governor of the Bank of England is
making a statement about the steps that
the bank and the Treasury are taking to
reassure financial markets we will also
continue taking forward the important
legislation that we set before
Parliament in the Queen's speech and
I've spoken to her Majesty the Queen
this morning to advise her of the steps
that I'm taking a negotiation with the
European Union will need to begin under
a new prime minister and I think it's
right that this new Prime Minister takes
the decision about when to trigger
article 50 and start the formal and
legal process of leaving the EU I will
attend the European Council next week to
explain the decision the British people
have taken and my own decision the
British people have made a choice that
not only needs to be respected but those
on the losing side of the argument
myself included
should help to make it work Britain is a
special country we have so many great
advantages a parliamentary democracy
where we resolve great issues about our
future through peaceful debate a great
trading nation with our science and arts
our engineering and our creativity
respected the world over and while we
are not perfect I do believe we can be a
model of a multiracial multi-faith
democracy where people can come and make
a contribution and rise to the very
that their talent allows although
leaving Europe was not the path I
recommended I am the first to praise our
incredible strengths I said before that
Britain can survive outside the European
Union and indeed that we could find a
way now the decision has been made to
leave we need to find the best way and I
will do everything I can to help I love
this country and I feel honored to have
served it and I will do everything I can
in future to help this great country
succeed thank you very much
they have the sinon and